we had a wonderful opportunity the other
day to pull up a big bag of popcorn and
get a front row seat to watching a
liberal narrative collapse in real time
this went viral it was don lemon on cnn
interviewing a british journalist about
the queen's death and don lemon
just like all the libs trying to use any
political or historical event to to
rewrite that event and then use it to
push his own
uh political agenda that is totally
divorced from reality
one thing i love about the british
they're just
they've just got a sort of grace to them
you know they're they've got a sort of
ease in the way that they
speak
in the way that they can make an
argument listen to how this british
journalist
just
artfully dismantles don lemon's stupid
argument about the queen
well this is coming when you know
there's all of this wealth and you hear
about it comes as england is facing
rising costs of living a living crisis
austerity budget cuts and so on and then
you have those who are asking uh for
reparations for colonialism and they're
wondering you know 100 billion dollars
24 billion dollars here and there 500
million there some people want to be
paid back and
and members of the public are wondering
why are we suffering when you are
you know you have all of this vast
wealth those are legitimate concerns
well i think you're right about
reparations in terms of if people want
it though what they need to do is you
always need to go back to the beginning
of a supply chain where was the
beginning of the supply chain that was
in africa and when that crossed the
entire world when the slavery was taking
place which was the first nation in the
world that abolished uh slavery the
first nation in the world to abolish it
it was started by william wilberforce
was the british in in great britain they
abolished slavery 2 000
naval men died on the high seas trying
to stop slavery why because the african
kings were rounding up their own people
they had them on cages waiting in the
beaches no one was running into africa
to get them and i think you're totally
right if reparations need to be paid we
need to go right back to the beginning
of that supply chain and say who was
rounding up their own people and having
them handcuffing pages absolutely that's
where they should start and maybe i
don't know the descendants of those
families where they died in the high
seas trying to stop the slavery that
those families should receive something
to i think at the same time
it's an interesting discussion hillary
thank you very much i appreciate it
yeah it is an interesting discussion
isn't it don lemon i love to she did it
so gracefully that he he couldn't even
fight back against her obviously he
doesn't have any facts at his disposal
he was just spouting nonsense and she
just so gracefully with a nice little
smile said well actually don lemon uh
the stupid point that you're making uh
really ought to be flipped on its head
because the british are the least
culpable people in the entire world for
slavery i don't know i'm kind of doing a
little bit of a paul mccartney man you
know i don't know that i can really do a
proper british accent like she's doing
it but that's the point that she's
making okay and don lemon is there and
he's it's just like he was hit by a
freight train
he just
and then hit hit the
narrative you had the narrative kind of
chucking along and then that british
journalist came because she had some not
only moral clarity and not only the
facts at her side but the courage to go
on cnn and say nah all that politically
correct mumbo jumbo it's all completely
bs don lemon and if anything the
africans owe the british an apology for
slavery
just completely destroys the narrative
don lemon
totally destroyed
with facts and
logic i i hope
i i would if we had more time i would
play that clip again just so that
conservatives can take notes on how that
woman did it because i bet you when
confronted with the same bs narrative
from don lemon
i bet you 99.9
of american conservatives would not give
anywhere nearly as bold an answer as
that woman did don lemon is pitching
this lib line that we've heard about
well the queen she's actually a sort of
complicated figure because of
colonialism and the legacy of slavery
and all this just complete nonsense for
queen elizabeth is not only not a
complicated figure she is probably the
least complicated figure in modern
history
she's just a woman who did her duty
faithfully
name me a queen scandal
there were scandals with her kids there
were scandals with some members of her
family maybe a scandal
from the queen
name me a policy of the queen or some
initiative from the queen that's really
controversial and i can't you can't name
one
they got nothing
but the only the only attacks i've heard
on the queen
that that the libs have been repeating
with any success whatsoever is you know
she knighted a guy maybe who turned out
to be a jerk
or she but they've got nothing or her
kids were jerks sure but they got
nothing she's not complicated at all
and then even the historical narrative
that don lemon is trying to push is just
bs this is how conservatives should talk
about it not only should we not say well
we've got to apologize for the original
sin of slavery forget it great britain
in america you know it's the original
sin of this country and we will we will
never get that stain off of our country
what are you talking about america is
not only not the most responsible for
slavery in the world america is
one of the least responsible countries
for slavery in the entire world
okay we we had slavery in america for a
very very short period of time compared
with the rest of the world we had
slavery in the modern sense of the term
in the west for a very very short period
of time compared to the rest of the
world
where did we get the slaves from because
africans were enslaving their own people
and still are today by the way
not nearly as much as they were at the
time of the transatlantic slave trade
but to some degree they still are
where did we get slavery from because
north africa not just sub-saharan
africans but north africans were and
continue to
be enslaving people
for a long time the muslims in north
africa controlled a major major slave
trade for a very very long time you
still see slavery in east asia you still
see slavery everywhere in the world
other than in the united states and in
america
and we fought a bloody civil war over
the issue of slavery
if anyone should be apologizing for
slavery it is everybody else on earth
except for us
okay that's the real answer
and i think it's silly to apologize for
slavery generally because it's a just an
expression of the fallenness of the
human heart
right not not a pathology unique to the
west
if it the only thing that's unique to
the west here is that we got rid of it
quickly and realized how bad it was
but it's it's a a problem that afflicts
the entire world because man is a fallen
creature so but so i don't think that we
all need to go around flogging ourselves
and apologizing for slavery but if
anyone is going to do that it should be
the africans and the arabs and the north
africans and the asians and basically
everybody other than the west once all
those other people apologize then maybe
the west can start apologizing for
slavery but until then it's obvious
that's never going to happen
so just
get rid of it it's a bunk narrative you
don't you you really don't have to hand
it to the libs you really don't need to
give it to him or meet in the middle of
reconciles bs just totally ignore it i'm
so glad you liked that clip now
you've got to subscribe ring that bell
get the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you